hour number three kicks off on the rich
eisen show with the new head coach of
the houston texans and it's been a while
since we have chatted with him joining
us on the mercedes-benz vans phone line
is lovey smith how are you coach
that's good rich how about you i am
better for talking to you i used to
speak to you on bears cam all the time
back in the day on nfl total access i
did we go way back in terms of those
conversations
rich we're getting a little older man
time is moving on for sure i know uh
i've got a lot of gray in my beard uh
how about you lovey
yeah i've been accused of having just a
little bit of gray no uh salt and pepper
it's uh definitely my gosh i'm showing
my eggs now i know i i'm you know i this
is uh something i didn't think i'd start
with but how much maintenance goes into
your beard man that's got to be a lot
like what what walk me through this
process coach yeah it was not a big
problem you go on vacation sometime you
don't shave a lot
and uh i had a
period of time where i didn't have to
and my wife loved it i said hey you know
what i'm going to keep this that's it
that's it and as simple as that
that's it because i get every sometimes
when i see the commissioner uh of the
nfl he he kind of makes fun of my beard
and i tell him my wife likes it and
that's when he backs off that's when
he's like okay i get it same here that's
all you have to say is that that is it
that is it so uh let's get into it um
coach so what are you doing like right
now what what does the head coach of the
houston texans do the week before a
combine two weeks before the new league
year begins walk me through what your
day is other than talking to me
well right after the press conference
it's about the staff getting the staff
together luckily we're able to get the
staff in place
uh quickly
and now it's just you know
about the team
uh
you know personnel
you know evaluating of course our roster
free agency coming up draft coming up
i've been to a few combines so
excited about getting back into the flow
to kind of start the process of adding
good players to the roster okay and um
is the quarterback that starts for the
houston texans in 2021 currently on your
roster
of 2022 currently on your roster
yes i you know of course you know the
first thing people want to know is how
about the quarterback position and
i love
uh what davis mills did last year
you know rich when you come in as a
rookie like he did last year and you
know you start off throwing against
going against the number one defense so
got a chance to see a lot of him and
then when he moved up and start playing
like his demeanor you know to make all
the throws he's smart
so feel real good about
you know davis you know leading our team
we just have to get better people around
him so um he's got a shot if not um
the front runner for being the starting
quarterback for the houston texans come
september you know rich as you say it
we've known each other wow you don't
give out starting positions in the in
the spring but
um yeah i mean as i said i love what
davis has done he's our quarterback
going into the season like all guys like
you know hopefully you know some of our
best players that played last year
you know new coaching staff starting in
but uh
you know replacing our quarterback there
are a lot of things positions i'm
worried about quarterback is not one of
do you reach out to david shaw at all at
any point in time to chat with him
you know i haven't because i uh again
i've been with him for a period of time
now but right
i know the background and i know any
quarterback coming from a system and
being around david i yeah you know i
know what to expect as far as that's
concerned and uh
so we again i like got a chance to see
him i like everything about him and of
course i've had a chance to talk to him
a couple more times since i
you know since i was named the head
coach here and uh
he cannot wait to get started and i know
his teammates love him too lovey smith
here on the rich eisen show do you have
any contact at all with desean watson
lovey smith
you know i've uh had contact with you
know from just being in the building i
don't really know michelle in that way
um
you know since he wasn't really involved
last year i know about his
his background and his history as a
football player
that part i know and um of course i know
most people want to know what's going to
happen with that time takes care of a
lot of things and time will take care of
of that situation too where it's a
favorable situation for desean and us
and do you think um
i know
one of the favorite coaching cliches is
you don't have a crystal ball in it or
you don't have one but the new league
year is a time that um is right around
the corner
is that the time frame that you and the
texans
are targeting at the very least in terms
of resolution oh yeah i mean absolutely
coming in as a new head football coach
we want to put the best football
uh team on the field and uh you know
some of the things where the quest mark
on what's gonna happen and yeah i can't
wait for all of that to get settled and
we can kind of move on from there lovie
smith here on the rich eisen show so um
walk me through the process of you being
hired by the texans and when you you
interviewed with them and when you
thought like you really had a shot at
the gig here
loving well i think you know rich that
if you're working
for any company any football team
you start interviewing from the moment
you become an employee there and uh
you know i was here for a year everybody
in the organization got a chance to see
how i did things what i believe
plus i have a history to fill in a few
blanks also uh so as far you know once
the football position was opened here
they start interviewing people
i was talking to of course organization
all along my opinion you know as a
as coordinated associated coach on how i
think things should be done a little bit
i mean i was asked that throughout the
season and the process and um
so you have to you know kind of talk
them on exactly when they start seeing
me this way uh but i talked to them
early in the process and of course
talked to them late in the process they
went through
uh what you go through trying to hire a
head football coach and
and after going through all that they
said i was the guy
and so you know uh much was made when
your predecessor david cully mentioned
in an interview that nick casario the
general manager gets into the headset
the ear
of the head coach during a game um and
that sounds you know
unique to say the least but then we we
heard that that was something that
casario did with belichick and the uh
for the new england patriots because he
does have
a terrific sense of uh being part of
practice he does things that other
general managers never really uh have on
their sheet is he going to do that with
you as well is that your expectation
that you're going to hear him and your
headset uh to help you with down and
distance and timeouts and things of that
nature during the fall you know you know
riz people do it you know a lot of
different ways you know i've been a head
football coach for a long period of time
i haven't had the general manager
involved on game day and don't plan on
it but uh
so again things were doing done
differently at different places uh we
have a system that we're pretty
conquered with here and
nick and i have talked about that nick's
gonna be available to help in any way
that we think he should and we feel
pretty good about that plan and uh one
of the finalists for the position that
you eventually got is brian flores um
and you know i'm sure uh
him as well as the lawsuit that has been
filed against the league
you um after making a super bowl after
being fired by the way after a 10-6
season after winning 81 games for nine
years
um with the chicago bears one of the you
know uh more demanding jobs in the nfl
this you know uh after getting a shot in
tampa this was your shot your this is
now your third shot after you having
some time in the big ten what is your
sense on what uh is the hold up for many
candidates of color to get a shot at a
an hc headset in the nfl what has your
experience been and what do you think um
uh has been some of the holdup here
in the nfl well mike
my experience rich tells me that you
know as you mentioned uh
i led my team to a 10-win season in a
16-game season and uh
organization decided to go a different
direction i don't know why and i don't
know enough about
brian's situation but sometimes things
happen that don't seem fair but you you
stay in the game and that's what i did
as much as anything i stayed in the game
throughout even staying in the game
being a defensive coordinator this past
year
and eventually if you belong in that
role it's feel like
you'll get an opportunity to do that as
far as making it better i think one of
the things you look at there's a time
risk when i was the only black guy on my
staff on quite a few staff
times have changed an awful lot
i think that's one place that we can
look at just not you know the head
coaching position looking at staff
seeing how many people look like me on
the staff
you have to be intentional about that i
know as you look at our staff we're
giving
you're going to hear us talking a lot
but you can also look at what we're
doing i'm talking about a houston texan
organization
i just know the numbers need to come up
and hopefully that'll happen in the
future
and one last thing for you coach or a
couple more minutes left with lovey
smith head coach the houston texans here
on the rich eisen show um
you've got uh a quarterback that you'd
mention had a good first year and uh
honestly um out of all the rookie
quarterbacks you can you can make the
case only mac jones had a more
um successful year on the field than
davis mills
and um
this is now a situation where you can go
on your second year with that kid if
that's the way it goes
you made mention that the bengals have
shown a blueprint to go from top five
pick in the draft
to the super bowl with a second-year
quarterback i know joe burrow has a
different situation and than davis mills
but
you're saying why not us based on what
you just saw from the bengals
coach
well you to me i just i kind of deal on
you know i take make reference to what
has happened a blueprint you know a lot
of times if you believe something you've
never seen it i mean why should you
believe that can happen uh
the bengals won
four games a year before
uh
with a young quarterback
and this year they were you know maybe
one play away from being super bowl
champ so that can happen
we're all dreaming about what can happen
and having faith on
that it can happen and uh so why not us
i know that yeah it's a lot of coaching
uh you know you know coach speak that
i'm giving you a little bit here but uh
uh
we feel good about
you know last year we won four games we
had an opportunity to win three others
and we're going to be a better football
team this year so hopefully we can get
things done
yeah and i noticed in your press
conference you didn't come out and just
single one of the the the teams in your
division saying we're gonna beat that
team you didn't come out and say you
didn't pull like what you did with the
bears you can come out and say we're
gonna beat the titans the colts you have
a pretty good
you made quite the stir when you could
when you took the reigns and you took
that podium in chicago for the first
time you said you're going to beat the
packers i think you had everyone at
hello right there coach i remember that
one you know
you know rich we did that for a while
and then they you know guy named what's
his name uh aaron rodgers
you know but um
uh we have some teams we have to beat
here too and of course the titans were
you know when you division champ i mean
you're shooting for them we split with
them last year
and there's you know of course the codes
the jaguars it's a tough division to be
in and that's hopefully we can compete
and have a chance to it's all about
getting into that tournament and
hopefully we'll have a chance to do that
all right last one for you coach um the
pro football hall of fame class came out
and i know a lot of keynes uh like
michael irvin and sapp and
um
that were very upset that the canes got
shut out um with andre johnson who as we
know is one of the all-time greats
certainly for the organization you're
now coaching for but the one cane that
did not get in that really sticks in
their craw the most is devin hester
not getting in you were his coach
walk me through when you realized he was
as good as he was
at the role that he played for your
bears
coach smith first off rich you mentioned
andre johnson and what a special guy
he's hall of fame worthy
i don't know andre as well
devin hessler i can remember leaving an
honest meeting and going down and i
heard about this guy devin hester down
at the university of miami
i went
we went down my son and i went down and
we worked him out i worked him out as a
cornerback guy was special man
and when he got on campus
you know think about a guy from florida
and never played in the cold and he and
he had as good of hands as you as you
could you could possibly get didn't drop
any balls but from the moment he touched
the ball you knew he was going to do
something special and uh i got a chance
i don't know how many i didn't miss many
of his touchdowns and you know coaches
talk about offense defense and special
teams but you can win games with special
teams and how rich the greatest returner
of all time
how does the greatest return of all time
not get in the hall of fame
first ballot i'm having a hard time
putting that all together
especially when you know you've got um
one of the most special moments in the
history of the super bowl on your resume
like he did i i was i will never forget
watching him return that opening kickoff
for a score when we all expected he
would do it and the fact that he got a
chance and then did it is one of the
most amazing things i've ever seen in
person were you surprised that tony
decided to kick to him to start the game
no but
not really risk because this football
man you have a lot of alpha males you
can't say hey he's bad enough we're not
you can't
bow down to any player
but rich that year you're right the
super bowl was special on that return
that he had
but i think the arizona game on monday
night i think that may be my favorite
one
of the you know the last score of course
you know for us to beat them that night
but there's so many special moments from
it
and the way the game is going now just
don't think that there'll ever be
another liking
is that the night that the the bears
were who denny green thought he was that
you were was that that night you're
talking about mommy yeah i figured i was
leading you right into it
did you ever have a chat remember that
night dude
did you ever have a chat with denny
green about that rant after it was all
said and done lovey you know in fun a
little bit you know i fenny you know i'm
a part of you could say danny's tree
also yeah and uh i can see why you would
be frustrated though with what happened
of course but did you ever say that i'm
like who who were we in your mind danny
tell me who we were
danny do you ever say that
yeah rich the thing about it we went to
the super bowl that year so i you know
that's who i thought we were too
that's all
you let him off the hook
i mean my gosh
thanks for the call coach appreciate it
congrats on the gig in houston we'll do
this again soon thank you
all right take care that's lovey smith
everybody
danny yeah hey it's lovey tell me who do
you think we were
because
you know
kind of thought we were good
oh and who takes the third game of the
preseason like it's
[Laughter]
oh my gosh
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here